I prayed every night...
Please Youtube!
Please...
(notice me...)
Please send me golden play button.
I've been a-- I've been a good boy
I got a lot of subscribers, you know, YouTube...
YOU REALLY OUGHTA FUCKING NOTICE ME!
I'M THE BIGGEST CHANNEL!
WHY DONT I HAVE A GOLDEN PLAY BUT-TON?!
My numbers kept growing...
from millions to ten millions...
And I thought at least I give a-- give a- get a diamond play button.
BUT WHO CARES?
WHO REALLY CARES ABOUT A DIAMOND PLAY BUTTON,
WHEN YOU CAN HAVE GOLD!?
Where do I put this down dammit!?
All these channels that abuse their play button...
They'll cut it in half...
They'll smash it with a hydraulic press...
Well...
I finally got it.
I got my play button...
And-- we all know...
What happened that day...
When the Fire Nation attacked...-- Sorry,
Just when I got my play button.
IT'S FUCKING BROKEN!
Congrats for surpassing one million...
OH, THAT'S COOL! THAT HAPPENED YEARS AGO!!
GIVE ME 44 OF THESE!
It was broken...
Just like my heart.
It was to hard for me to deal with...
And I had to sell it.
I had to sell my golden play button...
To a random stranger.
Today, it all CHANGES!
I got package...
From YouTube.
Let's look...
OHHHHHHH!
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!
YES!
Finally...
Finally!
Fi-- *coughs*
FINALLY, IT'S HERE!
Aw, I'm so happy!
Wait...
The fuck is this?
PewDiePie!?
What--
WHAT AM I GONNA DO WITH THIS?
THAT'S NOT THE ONE I WANTED!
Hey Romanian!
Five pounds and it's yours.
Well... you know what? 20 will be just fine.
Thank you, Romanian.
Good bye.
I don't ever wanna see that fucking thing again.
Disgusting.
Wait...
What is this?
No...
Could it be?
*gasp*
Another package from YouTube!
Can't reach...
Please...
Please let it be the one...
Ohh--
Ohhh-- Ohhhhhhhh!
OHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!
YES!
Yes...
Ahhh
YES!
If you work hard...
And if you create a second channel,
and bitch enough to YouTube about it,
you will actually get another one.
Jack SepticEye2...
My favorite channel.
Ahhh.
I've been subscribed...
Since the very beginning.
Such a big fan of Jack SepticEye2. It's such a great channel...
It's just such a great fuckin' channel.
Ohh I see my own face in it, and it's beautiful...
Ohhh, you Irish piece of shit.
This is going... S-- Right here,
Where everyone can see it.
That looks really nice.
That's gonna be in all my videos now, how about that JackSepticEye?
I forgot what this video was about...
Umm, we got a golden play button-- Finally.
The golden play button that we deserve!
I've never felt this empowered as a woman...
I wanna thank all my viewers...
All my SepticEyes...
Without your support, I could never have done this...
It means the world to me.
You know, when I started doing my channel, I never expected that it would get a million subs.
It-- It's just incredible.
I don't know, I-- I'm just so-- Appreciative of all your support...
And...
The fact that we-- This really shows it...
In one plaque-- This plaque means so much
It's not just a plaque.
It's a statement...
And that statement is...
JackSepticEye is a little bitch.
I'm sorry,
This is too funny. It makes me so-- it makes me-- it makes me genuinely happy.
So yeah, let me know what other channels we should make next!
And I'll see you bros in the next video.
As always, stay-- Stay-- Stay awesome, Septipliers...